PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
Hey, everyone.
How are you?
Are you excited
about this episode?
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Welcome to AI Adventures, where
we explore the art, science,
and tools of machine learning.
I am Priyanka Vergadia
and in this episode,
I'm going to show
you a tool that
enables you to automatically
translate your video and audio
content to text in real time.
World has become rather
small with technology.
We are all customers of
services that are made
in another part of the world.
So we experience situations
where the audio or video
is in a language
that we don't speak,
and as a developer
of such global apps,
we clearly need to overcome
the language barrier,
and it's not as
simple as it seems.
But what's so
complicated about it?
It's the data and the
files, because they are not
in the form of text.
We have to first convert
original data into text
by using speech to text
to get a transcription.
Then we need to feed
those transcriptions
into the Translation API
to get the translated text.
These are a lot of steps,
which cause a lot of friction
and add latency along the way.
And it is much harder to get
a good quality translation
because you might lose context
while splitting sentences.
So you eventually
make a trade off
between quality, speed,
and ease of deployment.
That's where Media
Translation API comes in.
It simplifies this process
by abstracting away
the transcription and
translation behind a single API
call, allowing you to
get real-time translation
from video and audio data with
high translation accuracy.
There are a large number
of use cases for this.
You can enable real-time
engagement for users
by streaming translations
from a microphone
or pre-recorded audio file.
You can power an
interactive experience
on your platform with video
chat with translated captions
or add subtitles to your videos
real time as they are played.
Now let's see how it works.
I'm going to say
a few things here
and we will see how Media
Translation API translates
the microphone input into text.
"New Delhi is the
capital of India.
Washington DC is the capital
of the United States."
Here we see that
the API is trying
to understand the input
from the microphone
and giving us the partial
and the final translation
in real time.
Now how did I set this up?
Let me show you.
In our project, we enable
Media Translation API
and get the service account
and key for authentication.
Get the Python code sample
from GitHub, and in the Media
Translation folder, we see
the files translate from file
and translate from mic.
First, we create a Python
virtual environment
and install our dependencies
from requirements.text.
Now if we examine or
translate from mic file,
we see that we are creating
a client for the Media
Translation API service.
This client includes the
audio encoding, the language
we will speak into
the microphone,
and the language we want
our translations to be in.
Then with that client, we stream
the audio from our microphone
up to the Cloud and start
listening to the responses
from the service,
and as we listen,
we are printing those
responses as an output.
This is also where you would
incorporate this output
into your application.
Now, while we are here, let's
change our source language
to Hindi and target language
to English, and try this again.
Now let's say.
[SPEAKING HINDI]
And it rightly says,
"Hi, how are you today?
Weather is very nice today.
We should go out for a walk."
Decent, right?
In this episode, we learned how
Media Translation API delivers
high quality real-time speech
translation to our applications
directly from our microphone.
You can even provide an
input audio file and achieve
a similar output.
There's a sample
in the same folder.
Try it out yourself
and let me know how
it goes in the comments below.
[SPEAKING HINDI] like or
subscribe [SPEAKING HINDI]..